a teenage activist sailing across the
Atlantic the highlight climate change
has almost arrived in New York grete
tuned Berg set sail from England
two weeks ago aboard a zero emissions
yacht the 16 year old will attend to
climate summits at the United Nations
and she wants to raise awareness about
environmental issues meg Oliver is in
lower Manhattan awaiting her arrival Meg
why did tun Berg choose to sail all the
way to New York that's a long way isn't
it Jonah good morning tuna burger
refused to fly here because of the
carbon footprint of traveling by plane
instead she chose to sail nearly 3,000
miles
earlier this morning she tweeted she
could see the lights of New York but she
won't actually touch shore until later
this afternoon a flight to New York
would have taken just eight hours but
Greta tun Berg wanted to prove a point
on her two-week journey across the ocean
what I'm concerned about is whether we
we will do something or not whether the
people in power will react and act with
necessary force
gale-force winds meant it wasn't plain
sailing to get here the 60-foot racing
yacht powered by underwater turbines and
solar panels was hit by heavy seas but
made it across the Atlantic with a zero
admissions carbon footprint conditions
on board weren't much better with no
showers and little privacy but that
didn't stop toon Berg's celebrating the
one-year anniversary of the start of her
climate change movement
she began striking alone outside the
Swedish parliament last August
soon students from across the world
began walking out of school too
demanding action from their governments
Intune Berg became the unlikely leader
of a global youth movement who call her
the voice of the planet I want you to
act as if the house was on fire because
it is earlier this month she told CBS
News that it's time to see if leaders in
the US
and globally are really listening they
say they listen to us and now that is up
to to them to prove if they have
listened while she's here tun Berg will
attend to global climate strikes on
those UN meetings as for how she plans
to return home Adriana that is unclear
at this point very good question I love
this little girl she's so unapologetic
and poised I saw her speakin in
Stockholm and she had the whole room
mesmerized before she even opened her
mouth she's amazing yeah and so
committed at such a young age just 16
years old it's incredible Meg thank you